PRESIDENT SHOCKED REPUBLICANS --
YOURS TRULY INCLUDED -- AND
DEMOCRATS ALIKE AFTER SAYING
THIS.
>> I LIKE TAKING THE GUNS EARLY.
IT IS A CRAZY MAN'S CASE THAT
JUST TOOK PLACE IN FLORIDA.
THEY SOUGHT EVERYTHING.
TO GO TO COURT.
YOU COULD DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, BUT TAKE THE GUNS FIRST,
GO THROUGH DUE PROCESS SECOND.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE AGE OF
21 FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF WEAPONS.
SOME PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO LIKE
THAT, BUT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LOOK AT THAT, SERIOUSLY.
>> Laura: WELL, HE LOOKED AT
PAT TOOMEY AT ONE POINT, AND PAT
TOOMEY, WHO DID THE POINT WITH
MANCHIN, AND HE SAYS, THAT'S NOT
IN THE BILL, AND HE SAYS, YOU
KNOW WHY?
YOU ARE AFRAID OF THE NRA.
HE ALSO ADDED THAT HE WANTED TO
STRENGTHEN BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
GUN BUYERS, THAT'S FINE.
THE PROBLEM IS, THOSE POLICIES
HAVE BEEN FIERCELY OPPOSED BY
THE NRA AND OTHER ADVOCATES THAT
HE SAID HE WAS STANDING WITH HER
MOST ISSUES.
A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS THIS A
LOT MORE, THE JEFF SESSIONS
POLLARD, REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
AND BRIT HUME, IT IS SO
GREAT TO HAVE BOTH OF YOU ON THE
SHOW.
I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE BEEN ON
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" BEFORE AND
THUS I'M LOSING MY MIND.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> IS NOT MY FIRST TIME, LAURA.
I'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
>> Laura: YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
STUDIO WITH ME, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WHAT ABOUT THIS DRUG BIPARTISAN
MEETING TODAY, HAVE THE CAMERAS
PULLED IN.
INTERESTING, SITTING NEXT DIANNE
FEINSTEIN, AND YOU HAD MANCHIN
AND TOOMEY WHO HAD COME UP WITH
SOME INTERESTING LEGISLATION,
THEN THE PRESIDENT KIND OF HITS
TOOMEY AND SAYS, YOU ARE AFRAID
OF THE NRA.
I DON'T THINK TOOMEY SEEMS TO BE
AFRAID OF THE NRA ON MOST ANY
ISSUE THAT I KNOW OF.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AND TOOMEY -- I DON'T REMEMBER
THE EXACT WORDS.
TOOMEY HAD A PRETTY GOOD
COMEBACK.
IT WILL GO ON THE BOOKS AS
PRESIDENT ATTACKING REPUBLICAN
SENATOR, BUT I THINK IT WAS
SOMETHING THE WORLD WON'T
REMEMBER.
>> Laura: RON, CONGRESSMAN, ON
THE ISSUE OF THIS MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, TWITTER BLEW UP,
SOCIAL MEDIA BLEW UP, PEOPLE
WATCHING THIS DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS ADVOCATING,
AND AT ONE POINT, DIANNE
FEINSTEIN SAID, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO ABOUT THESE WEAPONS
OF WAR, AND HE BASICALLY SEEMED
TO SAY, WELL, WE SHOULD LOOK AT
THAT TOO, AND THEN IT MAY BE
EITHER AN ALL-OUT PAN -- IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO FOLLOW.
SHE SEEMED TO BE RUBBING HER
HANDS TOGETHER AND SAYING, OH,
GOODY.
MAYBE THIS WAS ALL A SHOW.
I KNOW YOU AND I ARE BIG FANS OF
THE PRESIDENT, BUT THIS WAS A
WILD THING.
IT WAS NOT COOL FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> WHEN I THINK OF THE OVERALL
DEBATE, NOT JUST THAT MEETING,
BUT SINCE THIS HAS HAPPENED, YOU
HAVE AN INSTANCE IN WHICH THE
AUTHORITIES HAD DOZENS OF CALLS
AND VISITS TO THIS SHOOTER'S
HOME.
PEOPLE IN THE SCHOOL KNEW THAT
THIS WAS SOMEBODY WHO HAD
SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
OBVIOUSLY HE GOT KICKED OUT OF
THE SCHOOL.
YOU HAD ALL THESE RED FLAGS, AND
OF COURSE, THE FBI WAS GIVEN A
SPECIFIC TIP THAT HE WAS GOING
TO COMMIT A SCHOOL SHOOTING, AND
YET THEY FELL DOWN ON THE JOB.
THAT IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THAT COMES OUT OF THIS.
AND THEN I THINK THERE ARE
OBVIOUS THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING ON A STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL
TO HARDEN THE SCHOOLS, TO
PROVIDE MORE VISIBLE SECURITY,
AND TO DEAL WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
I MEAN, ALL THAT STUFF COULD BE
DEALT WITH.
I THINK YOU GET REALLY GOOD EVEN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I THINK WHEN YOU START GOING
DOWN THE WATERS THAT DIANNE
FEINSTEIN WANTS TO GO DOWN,
THAT'S NOT GOING TO GO.
>> Laura: TAKE THE GUNS AND GO
TO THE COURT LATER, I WASN'T
FOLLOWING THAT.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BAD BLOOD
BETWEEN JEFF SESSIONS, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND
DONALD TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT STARTED BY SAYING,
"WHY IS AG JEFF SESSIONS ASKING
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE POTENTIALLY MASSIVE
VISOR ABUSE, IT WILL TAKE
FOREVER, ALREADY DELETE THE
REPORTS ON COMEY.
IT IS IN THE IGA AND OBAMA GUY,
WHY NOT USE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THIS IS DISGRACEFUL."
HIS OWN STAFF OF LAWYERS AND
INVESTIGATORS, ET CETERA.
BRIT, LET'S GO TO YOUR FIRST,
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE WITH THIS
CONTINUED FRUSTRATION, THE
PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY HAS WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, IS THIS WHY?
I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
CONCEPTION OF WHAT AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS SUPPOSED TO BE IS HIS
POLITICAL PROTECTOR, HIS
POLITICAL AND LEGAL PROTECTOR.
AS YOU AND I BOTH KNOW, THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S POSTER.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO ADVISE THE
PRESIDENT ON LEGAL AND PERHAPS
ETHICAL MATTERS BUT HE IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO RUN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO RUN INTERFERENCE
POLITICALLY OR LEGALLY FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
DISAPPOINTED FROM THE JUMP WITH
SESSIONS BECAUSE HE THOUGHT
SESSIONS WOULD BE HELPING HIM
OUT IN DEALING WITH THE RUSSIAN
MATTER AND SO ON, AND SESSIONS,
QUITE PROPERLY, AND MY VIEW,
RECUSED HIMSELF, AND IN THIS
INSTANCE, QUITE PROPERLY, TURNED
TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE ALLEGED MISCONDUCT
BY THE APARTMENT RATHER THAN
HAVING JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
LAWYERS INVESTIGATE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS CLEARLY
OFF-BASE HERE AND I THINK THE
NATION HAS BEEN WELL SERVED BY
JEFF SESSIONS.
WE SHOULD HOPE JUST TO MAKE
SESSION SHOULD STAY ON THE JOB
REGARDLESS OF HIS HAZING.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN
DeSANTIS, HE STAYED ON THIS
MATTER, AND HE SEEMS TO DISAGREE
ON THE BEST WAY TO PURSUE THIS.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, LAURA.
HE IS A FINE GUY, BUT HE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            P
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            E
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            S
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            G
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            T
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            Y
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            U
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            R
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            P
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            W
HAVE ANY PROSECUTOR            R
, HE WILL OFFER REPORTS AND
WRITE A RECOMMENDATION, AND
THERE IS A TIME AND PLACE, BUT
FROM WHAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
LAST SIX OR SEVEN MONTHS, SCORES
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN DEMOTED
WHO
OR WHO HAVE TO LEAVE THEM
AGENCIES, A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
OFFENSES, YOU NEED A SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHO CAN ACTUALLY PURSUE
THOSE MATTERS, SOMEBODY FROM
OUTSIDE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
NOT AFRAID TO OFFEND THE
APPLECART.
THE IG IS NOT GOING TO CUT IT.
>> IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A QUICK
INVESTIGATION THAT WON'T TAKE
VERY LONG, AS THE CONGRESSMAN
SUGGESTS HE LIKE TO SEE, THE
LAST THING YOU NEED IS ANOTHER
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THEY FAMOUSLY TAKE FOREVER, THEY
RUN FAR AFIELD FROM THEIR
ORIGINAL PURPOSE.
I HAVE HAD CONSTITUTIONAL
DOUBTS, REGARDLESS OF THAT, A
BAD IDEA ANYWAY, AND THE LAST
THING ON EARTH WE NEED IS
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE.
>> Laura: OTHER THAN
JARED KUSHNER AND IVANKA TRUMP,
THE ONLY OTHER PERSON THAT HAS
BEEN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, BY
HIS SIDE ON THE CAMPAIGN OR
GOVERNING MODE, HAS BEEN
HOPE HICKS, AND TODAY IT WAS
ANNOUNCED SHE WILL BE LEAVING
THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE COMING
WEEKS.
HOW BIG OF A STORY IS THIS,
BRIT, AND WILL THAT FURTHER,
PERHAPS, DESTABILIZE THE
SITUATION IN THE WEST WING?
>> I THINK SHE IS A LOSS TO THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE TRUSTED
HER, AND BY ALL REPORTS, SHE WAS
VERY ABLE.
WHY MAKE WISE, AS JOHN KELLY
SAID, BEYOND HER YEARS MAKE
YEARS, I THINK STEERED HIM AWAY
FROM HIS OWN IMPULSES AND
SHOWCASE WHAT HE DID WELL.
SHE IS A LOSS.
I DON'T THINK THAT HER DEPARTURE
IS ANY KIND OF SCANDAL OR
REFLECTS BADLY ON HER.
I SUSPECT SHE HAS HAD ENOUGH IN
TWO YEARS, AND THAT IS A PRETTY